un tipo de problema muy común que se ve
en muchos cursos de cálculo
multivariable dice algo como lo
siguiente dice encuentra y clasifica
todos los puntos críticos de alguna
función que nos darán eventualmente en
este caso tenemos la función que depende
de dos variables xy y que es 3x cuadrada
porque menos de kubica menos 3x cuadrada
menos 3 g cuadrada muy bien y antes que
nada lo que quizás valdría la pena
mencionar es que significa el término
punto crítico verdad el punto crítico
básicamente es un punto verdad del
espacio de entradas en donde el
gradiente se anula verdad entonces lo
que tendríamos es un punto verdad donde
el gradiente de nuestra función digamos
un punto equis y un punto en donde el
gradiente se anula y por supuesto cuando
pensamos en que se anula es decir que
sea el cero estamos pensándolo como
vector verdad y esto básicamente lo
podríamos necesitar para cuando
quisiéramos clasificar
puntos como máximos mínimos o puntos y
la verdad ahora bien tenemos otro punto
en nuestro problema y dice clasifica
estos puntos críticos y en en realidad
lo que significa clasificar es
determinar justamente si estos puntos
críticos son máximos mínimos o puntos y
allá muy bien entonces vamos a tratar de
hallar primero los puntos críticos y
para eso pues básicamente tenemos que
buscar cuando el gradiente se anula es
decir cuando ambas derivadas parciales
se hacen cero verdad entonces calculamos
primero la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de x muy bien entonces
derivamos estos términos con respecto de
x entonces aquí ya es como una constante
y entonces al derivar esta parte
tendremos 6x por qué verdad menos verdad
a no aquí tendríamos una constante
entonces en realidad al derivar lo nos
da cero y luego tenemos menos 3x
cuadrada al derivar lo nos da menos 6
esto solo depende de ella así que es una
constante y esta es nuestra derivada
parcial con respecto de x vamos a
calcular ahora la derivada parcial de
nuestra función f con respecto de y muy
bien la derivada parcial con respecto de
ahora este término es una constante
verdad 3x cuadrada tendríamos la
derivada de esto es 3x cuadrada verdad
porque la derivada de jenson y ahora
derivamos menos cúbica entonces esto es
menos 3 g cuadrada
este término sólo depende de x así que
se anula al derivar lo y finalmente al
derivar esto nos queda menos 6 de verdad
y nosotros en esencia lo que queremos es
que estas dos derivadas parciales sean
igual a 0 verdad entonces cuando
igualamos a 0 la primera expresión lo
que podríamos hacer primero es una
factorización podemos factorizar 6x y
aquí 6x tendría que multiplicar ayer
para que nos dé el primer término y
luego tendría que multiplicar a menos 1
para que nos dé
- 6x y esto es lo que tiene que ser
igual a 0 verdad entonces lo que podemos
ver es que tenemos un producto de 2
números que nos da 0 entonces el primero
es 0 o el segundo es 0 esto quiere decir
que x tendría que ser 0 entonces de aquí
x es igual a 0 o bien que tendría que
ser igual a 1 verdad y eso es para que
esta expresión nos dé 0 entonces este
tendría que ser digamos el primer
requisito verdad para que sea punto
crítico
ahora bien podemos utilizar esta
información en nuestra segunda ecuación
que queremos igualar a 0 verdad entonces
podríamos suponer primero que x es igual
a 0 verdad y veamos qué es lo que
pasaría entonces si x es igual a 0 que
es nuestra primera condición verdad y lo
sustituimos en esta expresión pues esto
se anula y lo que nos queda es menos 3
de cuadrada menos 6 igual a 0 verdad
entonces nuevamente aquí podríamos
factorizar
menos tres y menos tres y hay que
multiplicarlo porque para que nos dé
menos tres de cuadrada y luego
multiplicarlo por más 2 verdad para que
nos dé menos 6 de verdad y esto es igual
a cero entonces otra vez si este
producto es igual a cero quiere decir
que esto es cero o esto es cero pero
esto es cero si es igual a cero y este
factor es cero sigue es igual a menos
dos muy bien entonces esta es la primera
situación cuando x toma el valor de 0
que era la parte del primer requisito
entonces ya puede tener dos opciones o
es cero o es menos 2 veamos qué pasa en
la otra situación qué pasa si ahora ya
es igual a 1 en este caso sustituimos en
esta expresión y tendríamos vamos a
ponerlo con amarillo tendríamos 3x
cuadrada menos 3 por 1 al cuadrado menos
6 por 1 y esto nos da
0 verdad eso queremos que sea 0 pero
antes vamos a simplificarlo esto será 3x
cuadrada menos 3 por 1 al cuadrado será
menos 3 y menos 6 por 1 es menos 6
entonces menos 3 y menos 6 nos da menos
9 todavía podemos simplificarlo porque
podríamos factorizar 3 que multiplica a
x cuadrada menos 3 y esto es lo que
queremos que sea igual a cero entonces
aquí podemos ver que 3 pues no va a ser
cero entonces quién tiene que ser cero
es x cuadrado menos 3 quiere decir que x
tiene que ser la raíz cuadrada de 3 la
raíz cuadrada de 3 o puede ser también
menos la raíz cuadrada de 3 entonces si
nos damos cuenta ya encontramos las
condiciones digamos complementarias para
que los puntos sean puntos críticos
verdad y en esencia tenemos cuatro
posibilidades primero tenemos el caso en
el que x vale 0 entonces tendríamos el
caso en el que x vale cero y tenemos
posibilidades en cuyo caso tendríamos la
posibilidad de que lleva al ga 0 o de
que lleva algo menos 2 muy bien y en la
siguiente situación tendríamos que ya
tiene que valer 1 verdad y tenemos dos
posibilidades la primera posibilidad es
que x valga raíz de tres y la otra
posibilidad es de que x valga menos la
raíz de tres y estos cuatro puntos que
hemos encontrado aquí son los puntos
críticos son los puntos críticos verdad
son justo donde el gradiente se anula y
lo que haremos en el siguiente vídeo
será clasificar estos cuatro puntos
críticos ya sea en máximos mínimos o
puntos y allá